okay so it's a real pleasure to have as
one of the coordinators of the semester
giving the last formal talk there'll be
some lightning talks after this and
xylem is going to tell us about the
energy and uncertainty part two thanks
so you had a lunch break but hopefully
you remember what Ellen talked about in
the the first part of the talk we
actually spent some time thinking when
we were deciding what to do for this
tutorial how to organize it and we
settled on on which what we what you've
been experiencing which is this where we
gave you 10 or 15 minutes of a
high-level overview of how the grid
works how the electricity markets and
stuff filled in and then what we're
trying to do with the rest of it is
identify basically four themes of
problems that are hopefully appealing to
segments of the of you that I think you
can approach pretty cleanly without a
lot of background and electricity
markets and if you see algorithmic
challenges in these domains that are
interesting to you that's the goal and
then you know we're both here for a lot
of the term and we have a lot of
students that are here during the term
and so we can help with the details of
energy throughout the way but this is
hopefully enough to get you intrigued
that they're neat algorithmic problems
in the space of energy and then you know
we can discuss them further as the
things goes on and so Elian talked about
you know chance constrained optimization
in online learning as two places and
they gave examples of where these are
used in electricity and smart grid and
these sorts of things today there's lots
of other places where these problems
come up as well but he didn't talk about
so if you're interested in these areas
you definitely should follow up with him
and me and our students and I was tasked
with talking a little bit about markets
and really since we already had you know
an hour or more this morning on
algorithmic mechanism design i figured i
wouldn't rehash a lot of those a lot of
those ideas are very prominent in
electricity markets and so what I but
why would I figured I'd talk about a
little bit instead is you know the
challenges that are of a little bit more
of an algorithmic nature and the things
that come specifically because of
features of smart grid and electricity
grids you know something that's a little
special to this domain
the two that I'll focus on our selling
tomorrow's energy today which is
basically news vendor problem and y news
lender problems come up so frequently
and electricity markets and the research
there and then the second one is really
on you know these kerckhoff laws these
network constraints and how they make
markets challenging and I just want to
give a flavor of each of them and
connect them to problem two models and
problems that I'm hoping you're familiar
with or at least have heard of before so
that you can have a nice entry point
into this domain if you want to work on
these problems and really you know the
goal of the whole you know the two hours
that we're giving you is to you know
identify that uncertainty is really the
problem for energy today and so it's
it's nice to focus on it during a you
know its program on algorithms and
uncertainty and that there's a lot of
models at this point that can be
attacked without being a Power Systems
Expert where you can have an impact on
the community with a one hop step and I
hope that we can have some of those one
hop impacts over the term okay so that's
that's the intro and now for the first
one we're going to do this by setting
you know tomorrow's energy today theme
and so this is really just news vendor
problems and we already saw 2 News
lender problems in eons talk and so just
forget about energy for a second and let
me remind you what a news vendor problem
is so this is 1800s I think 1888 if am I
remembering correctly is the first time
somebody talked about news vendor
problems so it's an old old problem and
it's basically the task of you know
you're going to go sell newspapers out
on the street tomorrow morning but you
have to you know buy them now and so you
have to figure out how many you're going
to buy today when you're going to sell
them tomorrow and so you to do that you
have to estimate the demand you estimate
how many you're going to need to sell
you get that D hat you purchase some you
know amount based on that estimate
tomorrow the demand is realized and you
sell if if you overestimate I guess
sorry this should be a hat that if your
if your D hat I guess if you realize
demand is more than more than X then you
lose some money right so you you didn't
have enough available to sell to them so
you left some money on the table and if
you're what you purchase is bigger than
the realize demand
then you're wasting inventory so both
are bad and you try to be as close to
the accurate thing as possible and the
question is how you do this so that's
news vendor problem and you know
uncertainty is really the difference
between your estimate and the
realization and of course you know it's
called news vendor but really it applies
anywhere there's where there's some sort
of perishable good and energy is very
perishable good you know if you don't
have large scale storage than what you
produce today you can't save for
tomorrow you have to use it now and if
there's not a demand for it today it's
wasted or in an air conditioner out in
the desert something like that and so
how does this come up today well this is
you know you heard a lot about how the
grid works million this is my simple you
know to slide reminder in a cartoon form
so if you you know for an algorithms
person you can really sort of think of
it as really the key thing that's going
on in the grid is that every time you're
balancing the demand the load with the
generation and you just have to make
sure these match and the way you do that
is you predict load and you have low
uncertainty this is my version of
villians plot showing how good we can
predict load so this is three lines the
purple is the day ahead this is for our
ahead and this is the realization and so
you can see there's just you can really
predict demand very accurately and once
you have the prediction of the load you
turn on generation to to match it the
things that take a long time to turn on
you turn on way ahead of tying the
things that you can turn on more quickly
you wait until the last minute to turn
them on and you only turn on when you
need and that's basically it and you can
do this so accurately that you can get
away with controlling generation with
markets so if you if you didn't if you
couldn't predict as accurate you'd have
to really depend on real-time control
and you wouldn't be able to integrate
markets as well but because you can do
this a day ahead you can really run
markets at a day ahead and then again at
15 minutes ahead and let the markets
clear and then only deal with the
remnants in the you know control so the
Economist kind of governs the system for
most of the time of the most of the time
basically up until the last few minutes
and then the engineer the control
theorists takes overin does the fine
grain tuning so that's how it works in
the markets you can think of a
caricature like this where you have you
know your real time a couple minutes
ahead
time 5 to 15 your day ahead market in
your long-term market and you know these
are the these are really markets these
are long-term contracts these are you
know signing a contract 10 years ahead
saying all of my wind goes to you for
the next 10 years these sorts of things
and really most of this you know this is
most of the energy so this is maybe you
can correct me somewhere around eighty
percent or more of the energy purchased
i think is in these long-term contracts
and this is more like ten to twenty
percent of the of the mouth but this is
a still a bigger maps that comes in
these markets the between these actually
i don't know alien do you know the ratio
between real time and day ahead how much
electricity is contracted he reverses
here maybe five to one
I think it's kind of like eight to ten
to one and then eight to ten to one sort
of recursively town but I'm not
completely sure yeah okay so that's kind
of how it's always worked what's the
change today well talked about it
basically you know the load well for now
we still have low uncertainty because dr
is a future thing for the most part
demand response is something that's
coming it's not really here yet it might
bring some uncertainty here but right
now this is still pretty low uncertainty
but the big change is once you have
solar and wind you can't control these
you can't predict them there you know
it's a lot of uncertainty on that side
and that means you have to change the
model you have to you know get some
control here so that you can react on
this side as well as this side and but
it means you have to change things and
really the changes happen because of
volatility and uncertainty coming into
the markets that's that's where the
inefficiency comes from and you have to
deal with it in the control too but it
changes come from it coming into the
markets and how does this manifest
basically you know if you have winds
actually and this is already happening
so there's lots of wind long-term
contracts I mean Edison Google is in
some sense and energy generator nowadays
they really have large portfolios of
wind power all over the US that play in
these markets and look at long-term
contracts and then there are programs
that the wind can play in real time
markets as well and you know what that
what happens here is you know if the
wind is blowing when you don't expect it
or is not blowing when you expect it to
that leads to price shocks and so you
got huge variability in prices as a
result of the uncertainty and wind and
solar and basically these variability
and prices can be countered a little bit
if you just have extra generation called
reserves on as backup and we do have
those and so you can think of a future
where to fight variability you keep
larger and larger reverse but that
counter is the point so you know why are
you having renewables if you have to
keep a coal plant on in the background
to make up for the fact that the wind
might not blow so that counters the
sustainability games and the huge price
vulnerability also is dangerous for the
sustainability games because you know
things like nuclear and that are slow to
react get forced out at the market if
there's these huge place
and these aren't just academic things
you know I like I like setting news
articles and so you know basically this
volatility can be enormous you can have
you know prices that are positive and
negative you know the prices can go
extremely negative in these markets and
they do frequently which is something
that's a little unusual when you think
of other market so it's exactly what you
think so if I'm not rather than me
paying you for the energy i'm i'm paying
you to not give me energy you're a pain
to consume right so you get paid to
provide negative demand and so you know
this this happens all the time all over
in the US and Europe and you know the
big picture result is a little bit
pessimistic actually so Germany is maybe
the one of the biggest investors in
these sorts of changes in renewables and
they've made some proud you know some
mistakes in the way they align their
bucket most people would say and they're
there what four or five years now into
their big initiative and greenhouse
gases you know their emissions have gone
up not down even though they're at
significant penetration of
sustainability there's a lot of factors
that led to this for example you know
reducing nuclear but a lot of this is as
a result of basically countering the
uncertainty of renewables with reserves
that are very dirty and so you end up
with a situation where you need to think
about how to redesign the markets to
avoid these factors that's kind of the
high level and you know Elyon talked
about this in the case of the real time
in the dispatch and risk uncertainty and
how you price dr and and all of those
those approaches for countering this in
the first part of the talk and my goal
here is going to be two more talk about
how you deal with procurement across
this time scale and how the network
impacts the inefficiency of these and so
the first one about selling tomorrow's
energy today is really about looking at
what happens where so you contract for
long-term wind how does that impact what
goes on in these markets and the second
piece will be about how the network
constraints play and create on certain
efficiencies and uncertainties in here
okay so the first question is really how
to renewables impact this market
structure and what could they do well
the natural things are we know we're
going to have the sequence of multi
timescale markets well should we add
more should the uncertainty mean that we
add more markets should we add markets
closer to real time so that we have more
certainty when these markets clear you
know all of these sorts of things are
very natural intuitive suggestions and
so you could you know move this around
based on how your predictions look you
could move it closer you could add new
markets maybe we should have before our
market in a two hour market and one hour
marketing and we get could we get more
efficiency by going to a model like this
they say these are the questions that
really drive a lot of the field and so
to give a flavor of how those work I
figure I'll just show you one simple
version of a way to approach those
questions and this whole in turn show
you why news vendor is so useful in
these domains so the first step maybe is
to think about suppose we have a
situation like this and we have wind
coming in in the long term how does that
affect procurement in the other markets
so if you're a utility and you your job
is to make sure supply matches demand
and there are wind contracts that you
have to take because you're you know
mandated by the legislature to improve
sustainability what does that impact how
do the long term contracts impact price
you know what happens in these other
markets so imagine a picture like this
and so you have prices for for the
purposes of this talk every are going to
all be exhaustion asst and random but
you know lots of good research is going
to making them in sajan asst and to
actually model the market dynamics here
but i'll keep it simple for the talk and
so think of you know prices coming in in
these long markets in these markets of
course the prices are going to be more
expensive on average at real time than
at long term contracting advanced it's
cheaper and so you have something like
this but the volatility of the prices
should be going up as you get close to
real time because you know this is this
is when the realizations of the wind
happen and so we'll look at a model
where you know this may be as a constant
this is something random that where it's
mean is bigger than the long-term price
this is something random where it's mean
conditional on the intermediate price
it's bigger than the long
various bigger than the intermediate
price and then you're going to purchase
some quantities these are what you're
actually purchasing or procuring from
the markets that's your goal and you're
going to purchase them but there's
uncertainty write your first thing that
you're purchasing them based on some
prediction of what's going to happen in
the wind and so at the long time frame I
mean think of this as really long this
is a year or so in advance so this is
basically an average case prediction
this is kind of like the mean and then
going forward you're going to have some
air in your predictions and your
predictions are going to get better so
so if you're familiar with it think of
this is like a martingale forecasting
model it's a little bit more general and
simple the way I've written it down but
basically you have some martingale that
you're predicting and you have some
improvement in your air from the
estimates at each stage until finally
you see the realization
and so then what's your goal your goal
is to procure enough generation so at
the three different stages so that along
with wind you have enough to get demand
and if I wanted to make this more
complicated and realistic i could have a
penalty cost for having extra energy and
disposing of it and and these sorts of
things but this is the simple version
that's the setup and now i should give
you an objective so minimize cost right
so you want to meet all the man to
minimize costs yeah so the wind think of
the wind is something that you've bought
it ahead of time you have to take it and
so but you don't know what it will be
until here and think of the procurements
or the conventional stuff that you're
trying to get to make sure that you have
enough along with the wind so so you've
bought yeah so you yeah so you've bought
the wind already in advance you know
this is from Google because Google
wanted to improve their image and say
they were net zero and so they sold you
a lot of wind and and then you know
you're having to buy you know nuclear
and coal and gas too yeah so right yeah
so think of this as a price external to
what you're trying to optimize because
you've you've already these are sunk
costs and then you're trying to minimize
the cost of procuring the rest of the
generation that's what the subjective
that I'm going I mean when you in real
time can you predict what the wind
generation will be in an hour so these
these real-time I could think of it as
five minutes ahead and for the purposes
of this model and capturing it as exact
but you know I could make that random
too if we wanted this is this is really
the simplest place where i have three
three levels and i can show it to you so
all of these variations are very
interesting some of them their papers on
not all of them there's a lot of open
questions about how these affect the
policies that result okay and so as i
framed it it should be obvious that this
is you know a three-stage news vendor to
a problem with martin go forecast model
as the as the look ahead and so you can
just derive a policy and so this is what
the form of the policy looks like hide
this for the moment so you can focus on
the structure first so basically you get
a structure where in the long term
you're buying the excess that you think
you'll need plus an extra reserve
quantity which makes sense in the
intermediate you do the same thing you
buy the extra now you know what you've
bought you have your new forecast so
this is again the
the extra that you think you'll need if
you're not already covered if that's
positive then you do it and you keep a
little extra reserve to keep yourself
safe and so you know it's going to be
more expensive to buy it later if you
miss it and sink and then here you clear
things up so it's got a very natural
structure you keep a reserve at every
level above what you think you'll need
at the moment and the question is how
big those reserves are ya this is
obviously I don't see why our
expectation it should be more expensive
so it's not an obvious right so so it
could be this is something that's a
function of the type of generators that
play in the markets so so think of these
as more likely to be things like nuclear
with low marginal cost and they used to
be things that are more likely to have
high marginal costs this does change
over time the natural gas becoming more
popular gives you things that are
cheaper up here than they used to be
yeah okay and so that's the structure
and then the big you know the math is
basically to figure out what these
reserves should be this should look
really familiar to anyone who has
studied a news minor problem before this
is just the critical fact I'll so that's
exactly like what you would get a no you
know standard news vendor problem except
you know the notation is a little
different basically when you go to that
you know second level reserved things
already start to get very complicated so
I can't write down an explicit nice form
for it although i can write a you know
implicit function for it and so you know
that's kind of it and it's a little bit
of a pain to work with already at this
point and you know if we're going to
start to ask questions about how many
markets are optimal or where should we
place markets we have to have a better
feeling about what this form looks like
to be able to answer those questions
mathematically and so you know what this
is now getting into some of the work
that Elia and me and others have done in
recent years is to say let's look at how
we can scale this and if we can come up
with a scaling parameters ation maybe in
the scalings we can start to see
structure that you can't see as well in
the ball and so this is also a cute very
cute like thing to do so a lot of the
queuing people here are used to this
kind of argument yeah
so far the sequential procurement based
on increasing information is different
than distinct from risk limiting
dispatch I just didn't use the
terminology okay and so now to do the
scaling one way to do this is just to
think of the scale is being kind of the
number of wind farms and so we'll think
of that coming out here and the scaling
is going to be on the problem and the
estimates here and so think of there
being a baseline average output for one
your long term ested is basically the
average so we scale up by the number and
we multiply by the average this is like
a lot of large numbers kind of
prediction and then as you get better
you're getting better yeah so we're
going to scale up again so there's the
you know the epsilon 1 for the
intermediate level and we're going to
pay kind of you know if theta would
one-half and everything was independent
this would be like a central limit
theorem type scaling for your estimates
but you know I like to think about heavy
tails and allow things to be a little
bit more variable and so if you think
about more general a generalized central
limit theorem type scaling this could be
anything between you know one or zero or
whatever depending on the correlation
structure or the heaviness of the tails
and your estimates and things like that
so you can really have a kind of more
arbitrary polynomial form and that gives
us some interesting things to think
about but I guess the easiest way to
think about it is just the degree of
correlation if everything is correlated
then this would be one if everything is
uncorrelated then it would be one-half
so the nice thing about this scaling is
it gives kind of what in sort of Orr you
or management science you say like you
know management sciences a journal
always looks for managerial level
insights and this is like one of those
equations that fits as a managerial
level in sight right so you don't have
to have much math to understand it you
get that you're expected for accurate is
what you have to buy this is what you
would have to buy to make demand much
supply plus a little extra and that
little extra has a very clean form where
there's some parameter that depends on
markets and prices and is very
complicated but it's completely separate
from the thing that depends on how wind
aggregates and how you can put
so you get this nice separation and the
separation leads to basically if you
want to understand the role of the
markets all you have to do is analyze
this this term the Delta and I won't
expand it out because it is a little
ugly but then you know you can really
just focus in on that and you can
understand the structure very simply and
everything you know I just want to
really make the point everything that I
present here is a really simplistic
model there's more general stuff here
there's lots of open questions but there
are also more general results and just
three since people are here for these
eliana and praveen have a really nice
paper on this which motivated our work
actually and they take this too much
more than three markets and then you
know this is the paper that I summarized
here and then there's some other works
as well for my groups but there's lots
of open questions about how to embed you
know penalty clause more markets and no
one has really answered the question of
how many markets are optimal so if we
get you know the motivating questions
are really where should the markets
replaced how many markets should there
be and I would characterize those as
open with any sort of general degree of
models their intuition for what the
markets just wouldn't always be better
so that's going to be my next few slides
just to motivate you to say that this is
an interesting question so so already in
this simple model i can give you may be
intrigued you a little bit here so
should they move move more close to real
time i know that's the question the
answer here I'll just say no and I'll
you can come ask me afterwards for why
because it's a little bit complicated
but it turns out that this delta term
it's very easy to see that it's kind of
independent of the placement of the
market and so moving markets assuming
that you're already in a near-optimal
state will help you which is a little
bit counterintuitive I thought it was
going to be very clear that it moved
closer but I think the more the even
more intriguing thing is should markets
be added things like having negative
cost because you'll be
no that's a network effect yeah so I'll
get to that in the second part okay so
the next one is you know how many
markets and here there's no general
answer to this but I can give you like a
simple caricature of two versus three to
show you that the problem is interesting
and warrants more study basically so the
first sort of thing is you know what
happens to the cost of procurement so if
if I only care about how much the
utility pays to get this generation
having more markets is certainly better
right because I can just purchase
exactly the same thing in the more
market case as i did in the in the fewer
market case and I could do something
else that would be better so it's just
it's directly better so the cost will go
down but the more interesting thing from
you know the societal perspective is are
you going to use less congenic
conventional generation because you have
more markets are you going to buy less
coal or less gas because you have more
markets and that's what you want you
want the total amount of procurement to
go down and that's where a little bit
surprisingly basically it can go either
direction and no the nice thing so
whoever heard my talk on the on Tuesday
on the queuing stuff we had this
conspiracy versus catastrophe
characterization of heavy versus light
tales the same sort of intuition and the
same sort of analysis and you know
insights apply here and it's a little
bit more general actually so but I'll
first tell me explain what happened so
so as a concrete example think of you
know long-term price 610 here this will
be somewhere in between and I'll plot
for you what happens so if the air is
our Gaussian so a place where
conspiracies happen in like tail place
then everything is as you would expect
with two markets there's going to be
some cost it's constant because we don't
have an intermediate market with three
markets everything's nice and monotone
and it's always better the procurement
is always less so this is kind of what
you'd expect going in early what I
expected going in three markets are
always better and we can actually say
something concrete about when this
happens it basically happens if this
condition is satisfied and this is you
know if you look at this this is density
this is cumulative distribution function
of the
character and basically this is the left
tail and so this is increasing sorry
yeah increasing hazard rate for the left
tail increasing has a rate of the CDF
and increasing has a rate of the PDF so
there's some structure there and and
that'll come up because the other half
also will depend on the hazard rates and
so I'll say a little bit more about it
on the other hand if we go to something
heavy tail say a weibull heavy-tailed
weibull you see a stranger behavior you
see that sort of if the intermediate
price is large enough close enough to
the real-time price you get this hump
where you procure more despite there
being an extra market and when does this
happen what again depends on the hazard
rates but but at least what we can prove
and neither of these are you know
necessary and sufficient so just you
know the best we can show right now is
that a long-tailed is important and and
here I like heavy tail so I'm going to
take a diversion long tail there's a
class of heavy tail distributions I'll
go into lecture mode and it's nice
because the so when I talked to you on
Tuesday about conspiracies and
catastrophes this had to do with this
one particular property in this one
particular class of sub exponential
distributions long-tailed distributions
they also satisfy catastrophe principles
but it's a more general class and it's a
class that's defined in terms of
behaviors of the residual life which is
also something that Nikhil talk to you
about on Tuesday and so we'll do a
little bit diversion about residual life
and how they relate to heavy tails and
light tails and residual life is really
the key to those two results that I just
showed you
I'll get to it so so residual life it's
it's going to be defined in terms of the
asymptotic residual life so residual
life is this remaining waiting time so
Akhil described it in terms of you know
waiting for a bus stop and you know
would you expect to wait longer shorter
so i'll describe it in a similar way so
just to get us in the mood what happens
to our expected remaining waiting time
as we wait for various things if we wait
for you know a table at a restaurant for
a bus for a response to an email you
know my students can understand this one
for me so so the table for restaurant
it's pretty nice and behavior right so
you get there they're going to give you
an expected wait time basically people
will leave you'll see people leave you
know your expected wearing any time it's
always decreasing every time you see
somebody leave your expected remaining
lady time will decrease and so on
there's not weird jumps there's not
weird monotonicity that happens right so
it's expecting a decreasing for a bus
there's this period where it's like that
you know until the scheduled time you're
expected remaining waiting time is
decreasing but after the scheduled time
the bus was supposed to get there maybe
something happened right maybe the bus
broke down for a little while maybe
you're expected waiting time is still
decreasing but after a while it's likely
that something happened in the bus just
isn't going to come and so then you're
expected waiting time starts to increase
again and then the email is an extreme
version of this like for me if you email
me if you get you'll get a response
within like the next couple hours or you
won't get a response right all right
yeah there's this sort of extreme where
you either respond to it right away or
it takes forever to respond right and so
there's this kind of very increasing
mean residual life sense to email
compared to decreasing mean residual
license photos and this this effects of
the residual life distribution really
connects with heavy tales and light
tales and so concretely mathematically
this is the residual life distribution
so this is the probability that you're
the residual life so there say the
distribution of waiting time given that
you've already waited X is this so the
likelihood that you're going to have to
wait two seconds or longer given that
you've already rated x
against in terms of the i use the bars
for the tail so this is the probability
that you your job or your your waiting
time was going to be larger than this
this is the probably that you're waiting
times larger than this so this is
probability given this that's kind of by
definition you can write that down and
so you know you can see this if x
mancell its memoryless as you'd expect
this ends up not depending on X so the
key here is that the time the
distribution of the remaining time given
you've already waited X is independent
of X because it's always the same as
your initial probability for something
heavy tailed like a Pareto it depends
heavily on X and it's going to be
increasing okay but this is a little bit
complex to think about and so most of
the time when you start thinking about
residual life's you don't think about
the whole distribution you think of some
statistic of it and so these are the
things that you've probably actually
heard of if even if you're not in this
area and so the mean residual life and
the hazard rate are the summaries that
most of the time people talk about with
these and so the mean is just the mean
of it so that's it your math and the
hazard rate is you know the PDF over the
tail and we saw you know this comes up
as the virtual evaluation function and
meijer nursing it comes up all over the
place and for the most part and people
often think this is a one to one but for
the most part heavy-tailed distributions
tend to be decreasing hazard rate
increasing me in the rest of your life
and light tale distributions tend to be
the opposite and so these are properties
that people tend to associate with each
of them it's not true that light tale
distributions are always increasing
hazard rate and vice versa so there are
lots of heavy tail distributions that
have an increasingly you know that are
not sorry not all heavy table
distributions are monotonic in this way
and some light to stale distributions
can have the opposite behavior and so
this this alone isn't the way that you
characterize this stuff and this comes
up right you know the bus wasn't
monotonic the email isn't monotonic but
they're eventually increasing and so
they have the heavy fail probably at the
end of the day and so this leads to the
the way that you actually work with this
stuff and proofs about heavy tail
distributions is the class of long tail
distributions and it's really just
looking at them
meeting behavior of the residual life
distribution so sir this was that
residual life distribution this was it
expressed out with near the conditional
explicitly and you basically just argue
that eventually you know for if you've
waited long enough if X is getting large
then you're going to have to wait an
infinite about so you can see the
relationship of this to catastrophe
principle that I was talking about on
Tuesday right there's some really big
catastrophe that could happen but it's a
little weaker than that it's it's not
you know the explicit characterization
in terms of the summit just says if
something is going wrong then it's going
to go really really really wrong that's
kind of the way to it and the name
long-tailed comes from you know you're
stretching out the tail with the tea
right so its loan because X plus T
versus X and the ratio is 1 so like like
the last one this is a subclass of
heavy-tailed distributions it includes
everything that you've heard of but
there are weird cases that are not
long-tailed and it's includes sub
exponential so not every distribution
here satisfies a catastrophe in school
but all the common ones do okay so
that's that's kind of my thing and it's
it's this that's really the key factor
for the two theorems that I showed you
before it's really this notion of if
something is going to go wrong it's
going to go really really really wrong
and if your air predictions satisfy that
then it can lead to the really
inefficient behavior in the markets
okay so that's that and and so you know
summarizing you know the the news tender
thing again there's this huge impact of
heavy tail versus light tailed
prediction errors on the efficiency of
markets and how you should design the
market structure and we don't understand
it very well everything I showed you is
for two versus three there's nothing
that takes it beyond that this might be
a silly question
you don't practice all about this story
yeah I know that that's true and so
these are these are theorems you know
with a bounds you know this is the
extreme situation I can come up with
bounded distributions that will satisfy
both of these but you know then you're
playing with little weird parameters and
it's not so not so fun right so this
kind of expresses the intuition I think
that that will hold more generally and
it's kind of you know just to hit on
that a point in terms of practical
impact of this one of the sort of funny
things is you know weibull versus
gaussian are the two most common
modeling assumptions made for prediction
heirs of wind these days and they have
completely different behavior in terms
of what you should do in terms of adding
a market for a tuber sister and we don't
know which one is a better model we
don't know which one is real all these
sorts of things so so in some sense this
this is highlighting that there's a lot
of uncertainty and how to approach these
problems okay and so you know this was
one example I just want to highlight
before going on there's lots of other
things you know we talked about wind in
the long term wind is really in the
short term in ilion talked about this a
lot and so there's lots of interesting
questions about basically where when
comes in into these market problems and
basically how you deal with uncertainty
and multistage markets okay so that was
the multistage market that's one thing
that makes electricity markets really
special and different from the sort of
typical algorithmic mechanisms design
work that we do in GT and in theory the
other is the network is kerkoff's loss
and so that's what I want to highlight
in the second part and again you know
the things and the insights here are
completely you know they're applied and
useful in energy but they're really
interesting well beyond energy and so
really everything that I'll say even
though I'll couch it in terms of energy
is about competition in networked
markets and I think this is something
that's really important for a GT as a
field to do beyond just its application
in energy so you know we when we in the
real world competition isn't in a single
well-defined market there's not an
equilibrium up price there's lots of
different markets that interrelate in
different ways
and firms compete upon across a bunch of
markets and we don't have a very good
understanding of the consequences of
constraints and connections between
markets so you can think of this all the
utilities satisfied us you know here's
my electricity grid but gas pipelines
airline routes you can think of
platforms in general uber Airbnb double
click Add auctions out exchanges all of
these are again networked competition
there's submarkets for different you
know types of users and add options and
these submarkets interact and you know
firms are deciding which ones to compete
in and how to devry divide up there you
know allocations across these and and
the exchanges are really fundamental to
how these things work and we don't
understand them very well so the
caricature here is in some sense you
have firms you have markets and you have
the firms can compete in some of the
markets and not in others and this this
matching is sort of fundamental to the
competition and the prices that will
emerge and the efficiency of the
marketplace as a whole how does this
work and this matching is complicated so
if you think of an uber or a platform
type design you're optimizing mat
matching if you think of a utility sort
of framework like electricity markets
that this matching is kind of given to
you and your such you you're trying to
do the best you can given the
constraints that matching provides or at
least the high level matching provides
and given that's complicated that's why
platforms tend to exert some control and
that's why we have the iso the
Independent System Operator and
electricity markets where its governing
that matching there's some market entity
centralized that does this matching and
takes the you know bids or productions
or whatever from the firms and allocates
them across markets and determine prices
and these sorts of things so yeah
there's lots of examples of this so
that's the that's the you know the broad
picture story in electricity I guess I
should before i go to electricity i
think one of the big questions in this
sort of market is you know efficiency
clearing equilibrium of that but also
market power and you know market power
is really a big issue here because once
you have a single you know in some sense
market power in a single market is easy
you make sure there's enough competition
there's enough firms they're not
colluding you're okay in here what is
enough competition
you can have a firm that is well
positioned in the network but produces a
tiny tiny amount that still has monopoly
power and we don't have any sense right
now of how to measure really market
power and monopoly and check for those
things in general market so in network
marketing aces so this is really hidden
monopolies are common and I'll
demonstrate that in electricity markets
now so this was our electricity market
case in the caricature I gave before was
just generation equal load to make it
one step more complicated it's not
really generation there's not you know a
single market where generation matches
load there's a network and so you have
generators on the network you have loads
on the network the network has edges
that constrain flow and you need to make
sure generation matches load at every
point in the net where you know some
sense the network is state so that the
generation matches load given the
network constraints so how does that
happen we have your market maker your
ISO and they basically take the loads
and they take bids from the generators
and these bids and electricity markets
are supply functions so you bid I can
supply this much at this cost and you
give usually a parametrized version of
that supply function curve that's your
input into the mechanism this is
basically your mechanism design question
how do you design the ISO and then you
clear that subject to network
constraints and the network constraints
you know I'll do what L ended and we'll
just think of these as linear
constraints capturing kerkove law so you
don't have to care what kurkle are just
there's some linear constraints here so
as a toy example to show why this is
hard and why this leads to problems so
think of just three notes we have a load
here we have two generators they're
symmetric they are uncap acetate 'add so
there's a load of six here you have two
generators here that could each produce
unbounded capacity if you ask them to
and yet there's a monopoly here both of
them have a monopoly power and the
reason why is you know so suppose we
have we produce three here well we'll
take all the lines to be equal impedance
which means that basically you know for
every one you send here a half goes this
way so if you were going to send three
to this to satisfy load there it would
have to go like this
through the network and so that's all
fine and dandy but we have this capacity
one here which means that that's
actually the most that this generator
consent so how do you get six well you
have to depend on the other guy sending
three as well so that'll get their two
to one here these cancel out now you're
at zero in this line so you could you
know satisfy way more than six but this
will already get you to six but now what
happens here if either of these are
strategic they realize hey you know I
can bid unbounded Lee large because no
matter what I bid you have to use me and
so both of these can drive the price up
arbitrarily you look confused finding
the way they do why can't you just break
the line and that's some kind of
switching have a switch so that you just
turn off that line so I mean I that
could be a response to this simple
example that won't help you in general
so this is you this is toy but you can't
write you can't just turn off a line
either
it just seems like a degree of design
for them rather than being stuck with a
particular network structure you give
you to break edges here in there if ya
know their utilities are looking into
this to some extent they're looking into
flexibly adjusting the configuration of
the network for reliability reasons for
lots of things but it's it's not
something that's typically done but even
that flexibility doesn't get away from
hidden monopolies I mean so for this
discussion you know suppose I just said
ok sure we'll do that tomorrow still I
would give you a network that would
satisfy the same problem like bringing
it read a review i do need the
capacitive on cocos loss so this is
basically the consequence of Carcosa
that for every one you sent here a half
has to go here that's the that's the
line constraints that's the way they
bind
so that's killer and this isn't like a
toy thing this you know we have market
power manipulation in terms of the
electricity prices not not the specific
way but lots of it and you know it
didn't end with the electricity crisis I
got a nice settlement on my bill from
this one in California where they had to
pay a lot of money for market power
manipulation and my favorite one is this
which was I guess the last year at this
point two years ago at this point so I
love it so they paid 650 million to buy
basically the second largest generating
plant in the Northeast Brayton point and
then they just shut it down and this was
a completely rational decision because
by shutting it down the network
constraints bound in a way that they
increased prices for the fleet that they
already owned and they you know the
calculations that I've seen they made
back this 650 million in less than a
year
so you know manipulations are possible
they happen and the points you know
nothing that I've said so far has
anything to do with uncertainty but
they're going to get worse with
uncertainty so so eliane was talking
about aggregators so SolarCity i was
talking over lunch with a few about this
you know their big model is to install
residential solar and the view is to
eventually pair it with you know their
home energy storage and now you have as
soon as that happens you have a hundred
thousand or more you know basically
distributed generators around large
cities and what can they do well they're
completely unverifiable so you can
curtail you don't have to give your full
capacity to the grid you can chant you
can decide when to plug into the grid
how much or to plug into the grid and
SolarCity can do this right so the
aggregators have the flexibility to
decide when and where in the market they
inject power and they can do this to
create place fun place locutions so we
have some initial work that shows that
basically first of all there's a great
algorithmic problem which is a nice
optimization impact with robustness
constraints saying how would you do this
if your solar city and so if you're
doing this we have a we have a sort of
nice reduction to dynamic programming
but but there's some open work on just
the algorithmic problem it's a it's a
really beautiful problem but suppose you
know you can do that and it's one with
uncertainty right because they might not
know the network structure they might
not know that a man so it's a great you
know optimization under uncertainty but
suppose they can solve it then you know
you can curtail less than one percent
and raise revenue by more than thirty
percent and this is in realistic
networks in Southern California and
where solar city actually has homes
means reduce so basically means not put
the full solar that's coming in into the
network and this is without storage this
is just basically wasting the energy not
putting into the network so that you
creates basically a need for electricity
elsewhere in the network where you
control
so so this this can't happen today in
the way the markets are structured but
this is one of the ways you know if this
were to happen it would be in the real
time market with you know with
locational prices exposed to the
aggregators the Artic possibly yeah but
this is this is one of the things that
really underlies how do you redesign
markets to handle aggregators that have
this kind of capability how do you
change a mechanism when uncertainty and
this is a place where uncertainty can
hide basically coalitional behavior
right you have a coalition in your
network uncertainty hides the ability to
observe what they're doing kind of
mechanism be robust to that so it's a
nice problem but I want to get to the
details of one way of going after these
so so the way one very common way of
approaching this problem in sort of
seeing the complexity of the network
creates is to look at network core know
and i'll come back at the end there's
lots of problems with this model but
it's basically the best tractable model
that the community has although people
like Ileana and kind of show are pushing
this and so cournot competition without
a network is I'm hoping everybody's seen
at some point but basically have firms
competing with quantities so rather than
setting a price a firm decides how much
to produce and so in the two firm
version just to warm up and give her a
familiar you have two firms they each
side they have a cost that to you know
think of things as they have a cost for
producing it and then the price
basically adjusts to clear the market
and how does that happen it happens
because there's a demand function
there's a function that says at this
price there will be this much demand you
know how much the firms are producing so
the inverse demand function sets the
price of the marketing that's the price
that the market will clear and price
something decreasing like that the
inverse demand function evaluated at the
produced quantities gives you the price
and that's your equilibrium that's your
notion and then the goal for the firm's
is to maximize profits so they basically
choose the quantities that given the
price will emerge times the quantity
they produce minus the cost of the
production maximum accent
so that's the equilibrium condition so
the network's version is the same and so
this is the version actually this is
from costa swim kits and others that
they presented it a see a couple years
ago i forgot to put that citation up
there but the network version is we have
a bipartite graph think for now don't
think of these as constrains they're
just telling you one or zero whether you
can send to that market or not so firms
decide a total production quantity and
how it is divided up among those markets
the total cost the cost is applied to
their total production but then the
price is per market and then they
maximize their profit which is given the
price at the market and their total cost
of production and how they divide it up
above the markets so it's exactly the
same form but you just have two sums and
to capture things properly that's that's
that and the key here is as long as you
know the costs aren't linear this isn't
separable and it's more complicated than
the single market case I notice that
this you know this isn't even equivalent
if this is a complete graph it's still
not equivalent to the single market case
you'll still get different behavior
because the markets are really separate
in the way they function ok so Costas
and when he presented this basically was
able to show existence and then there's
some follow-up work actually
simultaneous work where they could look
at the efficiency of computing
equilibria in these sorts of markets and
that's kind of where it stands point the
only other thing that's so there's some
nice results there on the computational
side there's lots of open questions
about this model still but you know
maybe the nicest piece that you can pull
out of there is there's some there is
some insight into market power that
comes out of it so you can characterize
the equilibrium in the simple case of
quadratic costs and when your inverse
demand as being in terms of matrix that
I right here which is basically a price
impact matrix it tells you it really
tells you the price so the marginals on
this are the prices in the graph in the
network and so you can read out from
that sort of a measure of market power
and I won't go into this because I'm low
on time and
I want to get to the electricity market
version but the key is that this matrix
can kind of summarize how a firm that
may not even be connected to the same
markets as you impacts your prices and
so it can capture the idea that there
could be a monopoly that doesn't even
for your market that doesn't even
produce for your market ok so the
electricity market version of networked
competition is a little different though
because here we didn't have constraints
on the network and we just sort of it
was combined it was capturing who could
send to what market and the electricity
market version the network is the
constraint right so the network it's not
a sort of matching it's a which markets
my production goes to depends on what
other markets or what other production
happens elsewhere in the graph and so
there's this Karkos law linear
constraints on the market structure and
you have generators or sorry on the
network structure and you have the
generators and loads distributed
throughout the network so it's a little
different but you can write down the
same way and the other difference is
this market maker and so for the
purposes of this talk just think of the
market makers really optimizing social
welfare that's that's what they're
regulated to do for the most part
there's a question of whether they
should actually be doing that but that's
that's the regulations in most places
so you end up with something where
there's a market maker that's optimizing
social welfare subject to the network
constraints and you have firms bidding
quantities at different parts of the
network men your universe domains at
different parts of the network and that
captures your model so that's it so
there's not you know the only thing the
only place where electricity really
comes in here is is the network
constraints and so but actually all the
theorems that you'll see in papers are
definitely for just general linear
network constraints okay and so the
equilibrium is Cornell which is the same
as it was before just in a slightly
different language and you can prove the
same sort of results you can start to
prove existence and you can start to
capture a little bit about the
efficiency of these markets but we
really know not that much I'd say and so
for existence there's some interesting
things that we can say so it'll always
exist under some of those iso clearing
mechanisms but there are some natural
clearing mechanisms like if you really
wanted to focus on consumer surplus and
you had this you know and california
actually for a while was talking about
maybe we should be really consumer
centric and how we regulate the grid and
allah then you start to actually get
problematic and equilibrium don't always
exist and and this is specifically but
because of market power manipulations
but if you're optimizing social welfare
or residual so for social welfare
equilibrium will at least exist which is
a good first step but that doesn't mean
everything is good so just to highlight
how much this can matter this is my
caricature of California there's
basically you know large generators in
the south large generators in the north
and a few over capacitated you know
lines between them and so the real line
here this is called Pat 15 and it really
is kind of a big congestion point for
the network in California and so if we
you know take this caricature you can
already see some interesting things so
if we had different clearing mechanisms
for the ISO you get very different
behavior in these two these two
scenarios so you get basically you know
this is the case where there an
equilibrium doesn't exist under residual
surplus and what I'm pushing here is the
capacity of this line so notice that you
know even in the uncompetitive and even
in the uncap acetate aligns none of
those three clearing mechanisms match
what you would have with a single
centralized market which is this dotted
line although the social welfare is
pretty close and the is so you know that
and this is just a you know fully
connected network with no capacity
constraint and still it's very different
from from a single market which is why
it's so important to study these network
markets and then the other thing is
these mechanisms really behave very
differently so if you if you imagine
expanding the capacity of your network
to try to help with efficiency you'll
have a very different impact with that
expansion depending on how the clearing
mechanism works and we don't really
understand this in general yet but we
understand it for some specific things
and so you know the big question
underlying all of this is really how do
you design that market maker even if you
are just trying to design it to optimize
the social welfare we don't know how to
do that and you know just drive that
home so the natural thing you know
suppose I want to if I'm the iso for
california i want to up to my social
welfare that's what california
legislature told me to do so the naive
thing to do is to set my clearing
objective in that optimization problem
to be the social welfare that's what
they do today it's seems natural and
intuitive that does not work so that is
unbounded Lee bad for social welfare
compared to the optimal mechanism that
you could use what is the right thing I
don't know
and so you know here's the unbounded lay
bad so you can prove you can come up
with examples that you know setting the
clearing mechanism to be social welfare
has an unbounded p of a price of anarchy
so unbounded efficiency loss compared to
the optimal and this is really scary in
the sense that you know Cornell is a
simple model if we had a single market
Ramesh has results from his thesis that
basically say you know efficiency losses
a factor of three two node network
already is unbounded for Cano so the the
bad case here is is that path 15 example
that I showed you I can already make
things unbounded Lee inefficient example
so what what optimization you know what
objective would minimize price of
anarchy is a clean open question that we
don't know the answer to so I can say a
little bit about it in the sense that
you know you know here's an extreme
space and we know that it should be sort
of closer to producer surplus than the
social welfare but I have no idea even
if you know even if I wrote down just
this space of parameterised clearing
mechanisms what the optimal would be I
can frame it as an SOS optimization
problem and for a specific case you know
compute compute it you know numerically
but I don't know how to you know really
characterize what that is but then I
think you know this is a you know a nice
clean concrete problem for network or no
but in the context of electricity it's
really not clear that Cornell was the
right model even to begin with because
at the beginning I told you what do you
bid into the market you bid supply
functions you say I'm willing to produce
this much for this price and you bid
this parameter I supply function you're
not bidding a quantity now corno is a
reasonable approximation in some
situations of that but bidding a supply
function is a very different thing and
you know a natural question and a really
important question is what form of
supply function should you bid because
you can't build an arbitrary function
that's too complicated a good space so
you need some parameterize class what
should that class look like and
basically the answer to that is we don't
know because almost nothing is known
about confident models where you bid
supply function in networked Marcus
there's a few papers the nicest one is
Wilson 08 if you're going to pick one to
read on this topic but you know just to
give you an idea of what he can do so
this is a quote from the conclusion you
know if the conditions for equilibrio so
complicated is to impede academic and
policy studies and it's impossible
implausible to suppose that firms
bidding strategies approximate in
equilibrium you basically throw up his
hands at the end of the paper and said
we can't do it nobody should do it maybe
we should look at different models right
and you know that said there's been some
progress recently Elyon has a really
nice paper looking at a simultaneous
equal over model for supply function
bids erman way and her students have
another paper that's just come out in
recent years so there's been some
technical advances that let you start to
make some progress in characterizing
what an equilibrium might look like for
situations when you're bidding a supply
function and so I think the time is
right to be attacking those problems and
there's people here that could do it but
it's really a wide-open area right now
Seager cost versus quantity with a total
quantity with their unit price over
total price you can think of it either
way so there are people that have
suggested both the reality is per unit
so the reality today is per unit but yes
yeah no it's not that there's something
there's not a decreasing point so right
now it's something that looks like that
and right now they're piecewise linear
bits in the real system and usually two
or three pieces as all that people been
ok so it's corner wave in the right
model and then you know notice that all
of the problems that I just exposed
don't really depend on uncertainty and
the interesting thing and this is wide
open is you know suppose I throw an
insert in shock and so you know suppose
the generator that's bidding quantity
has a portfolio that includes wind so
they don't actually know how much
quantity that will have available to
them in so that's impacting your place
zero results about competition among
wind providers in network cuda oh and
then you know connecting the two parts
this is now in the real time this is
happening after the long term
procurement how does the long term prove
no can we do a new vendor problem with
network constraints again completely
open
okay and that's where I'll and so you
know my goal was more mainly to show you
open problems and to highlight you know
news vendor pipe bombs multi stage is
crucial all over electricity markets and
that's something that we tend to not
think too much about in the TCS a GT
type communities and these network
constraints and network markets really
being the front one of the fundamental
challenges to the real time and I think
both of them are really rich space it's
at this point where there's preliminary
results but nothing is closed off
hopefully this motivates some of you at
least to come talk to eliana me and
others about energy problems over the
next couple months okay that's it thanks